green home grant vouchers the green home
grant
though what a terrible name hey what's
up my name is samuel leeds and in this
video i'm going to be talking about the
green
home grant vouchers these are vouchers
that the government are giving to
english landlords
or and homeowners that you can spend on
your home or on your property investment
to make it more green now of course i'm
not talking green
physically i'm talking make it more
energy efficient this is to help with
the insulation
of the property also to help lower the
carbon dioxide
in the home and you might think i don't
really care about insulation and carbon
dioxide
but actually if you insulate your
property better
it's going to mean that you could save
up to around about 600 pounds
per year on energy bills because the epc
the energy performance certificate is
going to improve and it's just going to
become a more energy efficient property
now you might think i don't care i'm a
landlord i don't have to pay the bills
my tenants pay the bills in the house
but i wouldn't probably be greedy like
that because if you improve the house
if you make it a better more efficient
property to live in then the tenants are
going to be happier
they're going to want to stay there
longer so it just generally does
make sense so this government grant to
make houses
more green is i think a really good
thing that might not apply to you
maybe it will maybe it won't so let's
talk a little bit about what it is so
you can decide if it's worth applying
for or not
the first thing to know is that you
could get up to 5 000
pounds given to you as a voucher
to put towards improving your home the
insulation or to reducing the carbon
dioxide now the vouchers you can't just
if you were given five thousand pound as
a voucher
you couldn't just go and spend that on
improving your home
it would have to be particular type of
improvements
which are about insulation improving epc
and that's quite strict guidelines and
also you would have to put some of your
own money in as well
what they're saying is they're saying
that the vouchers will cover up to
two-thirds not up to i think just
two-thirds of the work
so in other words to get five thousand
pounds you'd have to spend
about seven and a half thousand pounds
maybe just over to be able to use the
five thousand pounds
if the work was only five thousand
pounds if my math is correct
that'd give you around about three
thousand pounds two thirds
to put towards the total amount so you
are gonna have to put a little bit of
your own money in
so there's gonna be a little bit of skin
in the game now you can get these
vouchers immediately and you can get
them from the gov dot uk
website i'll put a link in the
description where it has
all of the details where you can apply
to actually get one of these
vouchers and get one of these grants to
go and start doing work on their
property
if you do get a voucher you have to
apply once you've received the voucher
you have to carry out the work by march
31st 2021 so you can apply for the
voucher now
and then you've got to go and get the
work done now should you even
do this what exactly can you do in the
property now i'm speaking mostly to
landlords and property investors
if you're a homeowner you can of course
do this as a homeowner in fact if you're
a homeowner and you are on any kind of
benefits
you can apply up to ten thousand pounds
grant from the government so it's
slightly
different if you're a homeowner than if
you are a landlord
also if you're a landlord the property
has to be in england
so sorry to my folks who are listening
who are outside of england this is for
people that own houses in england only
and if you're epc at the moment i mean
every house has to have an energy
performance certificate
and just to rent out a house at the
absolute worst
it needs to be i think it's e if it's
worse than e if your energy performance
certificate is an
f or worse than that you cannot rent out
that property as a buy to let
if it's an e it's pretty bad so what
they're saying is they're saying
if it's worse than an e forget it you're
on your own
if it's an e or above we can help you
and we can help you improve it to maybe
a c
or a b or maybe even an a which is going
to mean that
this the property is running really
really really efficiently
so what makes properties run efficiently
so there's two main things
so there's the primary things that you
need to do which is basically insulation
maybe insulate the floor underneath the
floor insulate the
the walls cavity wall insulation
roof insulation loft or bedroom
or room in a loft insulation to insulate
the roof whether it be a pitched roof or
whatever kind of roof it is
this is insulation that's the primary
cause they are looking for you to
put some of some form of this insulation
into the property
but then if you're doing that you can
then use the
the the grant to get secondary uh
issues which might be even things like
uh double glazing
so if your house hasn't got double
glazing if it's just single glazed
you'll be able to apply for double
glazing but
only if you use the grant to get a
primary
uh installation done as well by the way
i know this sounds really complicated
i'm going to be pointing you to a
website where you can fill out put your
postcode in
and it's really straightforward and it
will show you exactly
exactly what your property might need
and whether you are eligible or not and
i'm afraid if i was the government i'd
make things really simple it'll be
really clear whenever the government
give out free money
they always make it really really hard
and they make it
very specific and very hard but if you
go for a primary
put your grant towards one of the
primary issues you can then put it
towards secondary as well
the secondary could be windows it could
be doors having more energy
efficient doors uh having the the water
tank thermostat or any of the heating
controls improved
that's a secondary thing so you can put
the grant towards the secondary
as long as you put it towards one of the
primary so that's a nutshell of what it
is
should you bother with it should you do
it i would say yes
if you've got a property that's not that
energy efficient and you want to improve
it
and you've got a few thousand pounds of
your own money to put towards it
absolutely do it there's no harm in
trying
so my advice would be go down to the
website
simpleenergyadvice.org.uk
that is simple it's not that simple is
it it's pretty complicated
simpleenergyadvice.org.uk and if you go
to that the
first thing it will ask you is for your
postcode put the postcode of the
property in mind and
it will then tell you what the epc is so
you'll be able to see
what your current or your most recent
epc certificate was
and then you can fill your details out
answer some questions it might take
10 15 minutes depending if you've got
the information to hand and then it will
tell you
what you can do in your property what
you're eligible to do
so i would advise to do it check it out
go down to the website i'll leave a link
in the description
as well and guys i'm always here every
single day
to give out property tips the news
what's going on with the economy
and how you can not only save money as a
property investor or landlord but also
make a lot of money as well so if you
like this video if you find my channel
helpful please do me a massive favor
and smash the like button and of course
subscribe for more top tips and video
updates coming every single day
subscribe turn the notification bell on
and i look forward to seeing you
on the next video thanks so much
[Music]
you